hello I'm Brianna and in this video I'm
gonna go over a lot of things having to
do with bash mostly the basics we're
gonna start off really basically what is
bash what does that you know how do I
even get around all the way through
configuration using different types of
scripts with bash so hopefully at the
end you'll feel a little bit more
comfortable working in the terminal so
starting off as you can see bash is a
terminal it is the terminal used on Mac
and Linux by default so it's a little
bit different than PowerShell when
people say terminal it could mean a lot
of different things it could mean bash
it could mean something like zsh shell
which is kind of similar or powershell
but this is all about bash so we open up
bash I opened up my terminal application
and on my Mac computer and the very
first thing that I want to type so it's
kind of intimidating if you've never
been here before but I want to just do
echo and then I'm dollar sign here so
echo space dollar sign 0 this I click
enter return this says bash so this is
just confirming that I am in bash so
find your terminal type echo space
dollar sign 0 if it says bashed and
you're in the right slot whatever I type
today should work for you as well unless
you have some different configuration
setup so we're here we don't know what
here is other than bash so I'm going to
type PWD so PWD stands for print working
directory and that just means it's gonna
print out wherever I currently am so
currently I'm in my computer's users
directory and then github teacher so
that's the user that I'm logged into
right now I can use PWD at any time to
know where I am which is pretty helpful
the next command I want to show is
called LS so LS is gonna list whatever's
in my current directory if there's any
files or other directories so here I see
I applications documents library what
you'd expect we also have an LS space -
al let's see if there's any hidden files
here and it also gives us some more
information
we see all these letters on the left to
talk about those later owner of the file
their permission level and then here the
dot in front of a file means it's a
hidden file so when I just did LS I
wasn't able to see those files like
trash Adam - history which we'll talk
about soon so know that LS and LS - al
are there so that you can see what's
going on in the directory that you're
currently in when I list files and
directories
I see documents downloads all these
things I want to make a new folder a new
directory called projects so I'm gonna
do mkdir for make directory and then
space and then projects new capital P
here so I type mkdir projects hit enter
it tells me nothing but if I do LS I can
see now I have a projects directory that
I didn't have before so I just created
an empty file that's it
using mkdir so I've made this directory
but I'm not currently in it right if I
do PWD and still in my github teacher
directory so to change directories I'll
do CD projects CD space projects what
what you see on the left hand side
changes a little bit that'll depend on
what configurations what you know that
can look different from computer to
computer especially with developers that
have been using bash for a while if I do
PWD now it's a little different so
before I was just in github teacher Nam
and github teacher slash project so I've
created the directory and then change
directory into it if I do LS here we see
nothing unless - al I just see these
stats which means I can go back so we've
changed directory into a directory but
like maybe I want to go back I'll say I
want to go back to being in this github
teacher directory I can type terminal
I'll type CD space dot dot now if I do
PWD I'm back and get
teacher no big deal we've created
directory it's good to know how to get
rid of a directory just in case so if
you need to delete a directory you can
do rmdir so mkdir to create rmdir and
then i'll do projects so when i just
creative just gonna scrap it now if I do
LS oops not LD if I do LS then projects
is no longer there even if I do LS al al
it's not there anymore
I'll go ahead and recreate that and kDa
our projects just so that we have
something to we're gonna keep making
some changes but now you've seen a lot
of the basics we know how to navigate
around we know where we are with PWD we
can change directories with CD both
forwards and backwards list the files in
any given directory make directories
delete directories it's already a lot
right with just a few really basic
commands hopefully by now you already
you're figuring out there's nothing to
be afraid of when you're when you're in
the terminal let's talk a little bit
about working with files so we've talked
about directories let's work with files
all files are case-sensitive with bash
this is important to consider as you
might be working with something another
program like if you're working with git
and the way get or any program five
handles case sensitivity might be
different than how bash handles case
sensitivity so keep in mind bash is case
sensitive
let's CD into that project change
directories into projects and I'm gonna
make a new file because we do LS which
there's nothing to create a new empty
file I'm just gonna type touch I'll call
it file one MD for markdown the file
format that I use a lot press return I
tells me nothing if I do LS now I see I
have this file 1 MD I do LS - al I still
got those dot files at file 1 dot MD see
who it's owned by and the letters are a
little different but we'll get there
creating a file pretty easy to delete
that file RM just RM file under MD
now it's no longer there some different
ways we can manipulate files let's go
ahead and make this file again we'll
call it file - 2 nd I've created this
file let's say I want to copy this file
so I want to make a duplicate I'm gonna
type CP file - MD and then the name that
I want the new copy to have so I'm gonna
call this file to copy dot MD as soon as
I do that I do LS I see I've got these
two files here they're empty they're
both empty but if file two had some
contents and it that would now be mapped
exactly to file to copy you can also
rename files just really simply so if I
do envy let's say I want file to copy
this new file I want that to just be
called file 3 so I'll do em V file to
copy down MD the old name and then the
new name I'll call file 3 I do LS AL
file to copies now all been renamed to
file 3 pretty straightforward so far
since we've started working with files
we've used touch RM MV and CP so touch
creates a file RM removes it CP copies
it and creates another one and env just
renamed or moves it to a different file
name we also have cat 4 concatenate
concatenate so this is a way to create
single or multiple files you can view
the contents of a file you can link
files together so view multiple files
redirect output interminable files
there's a lot you can do with cat since
these two files are empty right now
let's put some let's put some things in
there so let's do that with a VI so VI
is kind of a different level so bash and
terminal can already be intimidating VI
I have to use another level VI is always
a text editor within the terminal you
might hear people also the VIN them in
VI are different I don't use either one
regularly so I'm sure there are a lot of
people out there who can go into
more detail than I can but it's
important to know a little bit about VI
you might end up in VI by accident and
it doesn't behave necessarily how you
think so let's let's use it to use VI
let's add some contents to file - I'm
gonna take the VI space file - MD it's
gonna open up file - n VI so already it
looks very different if I tried to just
type anything it might not work once
you're in VI mode to actually insert you
press I or J so there's two two modes of
VI there's insert and command so I'm
gonna type a I hit I on my keyboard and
now we can see at the bottom it says
insert now I'd be able to type so I'm
gonna say file - is the best file in the
entire directory so I've made my changes
now what do I won't do right how do I
get out if I press ENTER it just goes
down gimme I think that's like how do I
get out of VI is the most popular most
asked question on Stack Overflow so here
we are how do we get out of VI first we
need to get into that command mode right
so I'm gonna press escape we see the
insert is gone at the bottom I'm gonna
shift so it's : and now we can see that
at the bottom that's putting us into
command mode w-4 right because I want to
save these changes and Q for quit I
could just do Q and it wouldn't save but
WQ will save and quit hit enter so
that's it I'm out of VI let's do that
again
let's do for file 3 so I'm going to open
VI file 3 MD first thing I do is type I
to begin insert mode start typing 503 is
a pretty good file - now my instinct as
somebody who's uses a computer is to do
command S or ctrl s to save but that
will not work the I the same way to work
on other programs to get out of this I'm
gonna hit escape to get out of insert
mode : WQ + Enter
we're done so we've kind of done these
basics of a VI just the need to know
basic so how to get out and how to get
in how to make some changes let's use
that cat command so you're gonna do cat
file tuna and D and it prints out just
the contents of file - that I just put
in there I can do cat file - daddy file
3d so I'm doing two different files and
it prints out both both of the contents
the contents are both of the files so so
far we go a lot right we've worked with
directories how to get around if I do
PWD and the first thing we really talked
about I'm still in my projects directory
LS I still have these two files here
file two and files three let's talk a
little bit about how to configure your
bash shell so what that means is right
now my bash is pretty monotone there's
just white and black if you're ever if
you ever see somebody else working in a
terminal whether it's on it video or in
person you know sitting next to somebody
on an airplane their terminal might not
look like this it probably doesn't look
like this I configure mine to have some
different colors that make it easier for
me to read which is some you know the
most basic probably way to do it but you
can configure your bash terminal for a
lot of different things so you can
include aliases so that I don't need to
type something small but I actually will
run a much longer script or command you
can configure authentication tokens for
different servers like git and github
let's start out with the colors so for
the colors the first thing we're gonna
look for is a dot bash profile and dot
bash RC so again PWD I'm in projects I
need a CD back into my main user
directory then we do LS - al so I see I
have bash history and bash sessions but
since I
haven't used the bash RC or bash profile
final yet they are not on this user data
mapping this user account if those files
exist or not by default will depend on
your operating system so Linux you
probably already have those on Mac you
might not that's okay we're just gonna
create it so we know how to create files
touch dot bash RC and touch dot bash
underscore profile bash profile is
executed for login shells and bash RC is
executed for interactive non login
shells meaning bash profile is gonna
have those authentication tokens that we
talked about
whereas bash RC is gonna have more just
general general configurations in it
okay so I'm gonna open up that bash RC
I'm not gonna do it in vim I'm actually
going to use my favorite text editor
which is Adam and to do that I'm gonna
go to Adam there is a way to configure
Adam so it's a you just Adam space and
the file name
I haven't done that let's see if it'll
work just by default Adams space dot oh
great so out of space anything will open
up that specific file dot and bash like
I just did means current directory so
it's open the current directory so
everything I see on the left hand side
here is the same I would see an LS - al
an open up this bash RC file and Adam
and I'm going to copy this which I'll
put in the video description here here
nope actually no not on pathan the bash
profile so what this does is this is
making sure that we only are sourcing
the bash RC from the bash profile if
bash doesn't know where to look it might
not behave how you'd expect it to you
might get some different errors and bugs
so this is making sure that the bash
profile is always looking for the
HRC to make sure it's taking whatever
configurations are there into account
also so I'll save that change in my bash
profile now when I log into any machine
from a console this bash RC is
automatically going to be called let's
go ahead and configure some colors we
pull up these different colors here this
is what I'm looking at so I'll put a
link to this little gist of code so it's
a little bit different if depending on
your operating system since I'm on a Mac
I'm gonna add this to the bash profile
so here's this script so this is going
to be affecting my get output
specifically so you could do that or
this one here this is specifically for
for get copied one I'll put that in bash
profile all of this this hash sign I'm
putting here is comment colors for it
gets output and I'll paste that in and
save and I also want to so this is
something I got from a friend I'll save
that doing that and then back in the
best batch or see that's right colors or
other text let's try this now here let's
open up terminal again there we go
okay so CLI color 1 enables coloring at
your terminal and then the LS colors
specifies how to color specific items
okay there we go so there's a lot of
different ways you can you know
customize this so that the outfit is
much different here we go PWD it's still
black LS - al here we see how you know
certain things look look different based
on if they're a directory or if they are
just
by customizing your your prompt and
configuring thing this goes a lot deeper
than this you kid what you can do is is
absolutely massive but the most
important thing to know is that you find
those customizations in your dot bash RC
and your dot bash profile okay well
let's move on to something else let's
talk about the internet so I'm gonna
type clear here clear is just a terminal
a shuttle bash command to literally
clear off everything that's on the
terminal so that you have a fresh start
clear alright so you can interact with
the internet and other networks from
bash that means you know whatever
program you're using can interact with
the Internet you'd usually want to do
this to check the network connectivity
or speed so if I type ping google.com
that tells me how fast my internet
connection is really quickly I'm gonna
press ctrl hold it down and then click C
to exit that so if you ever stuck in a
mode it's either VI mode right and then
you would do escape : WQ or something
like this where there's an operation
running a system task then I would do
ctrl + C to exit that um so interacting
with the internet a lot of different CLI
tools will access the internet git is a
great example of this so I'd have my
remote repository on github.com my local
repository on my computer I can interact
with that entirely from bash and that
will be done via the Internet so just
remember anything that you do in the
shell right you are not automatically
just on your own computer which is a
great thing but also good to know in
case you might be making changes to
something let's move on to what else can
you do from bash so we've done quite a
bit already right we've created files
we've navigated around we know how to
get out of V and get in or get out of VI
into the I let's talk about how to do
some more advanced things mostly scripts
so as an example I would like
to show you this script and we're gonna
create it we're gonna run it run it make
it work
so this script here this example is what
I use before I teach class if I was
talking about it quits certain
applications it hides my dog because I
really don't want slack notifications
coming up while I'm teaching a class and
it opens certain applications so mouse
pose a and moon which are things I used
to show my mouse and move windows around
make sure those are open make sure
certain browsers are open and even
triggers other scripts like the teach
class script one that we're going to
create is really simple so here we see
the top line is this pound sign
exclamation bin bash that just tells
bash that this file is actually a bash
script so I'm gonna go ahead and go back
to the bash here I'm going to CD out of
this repositories and back in projects
can see that here I'm going to let's
take a look at this script okay so it's
just a good morning world so I'm going
to touch good morning I'll just create a
file called good morning and if I going
to VI good morning so now I'm in VI okay
next let's insert if I type eyes that
were in insert mode and at the top is
that pound exclamation bin slash
exclamation slash bin slash bash enter
clear and when I just clear the prompt
right like you could do as any
standalone command and echo which we
haven't talked about yet echo just has
the kernel has bash print out exactly
what's in close so echo good good
morning world will then have the
terminal print that out echo is a really
really useful command when you're
working with shell scripts because
frequently through your script you might
want to know you know like a console a
lot of kind of thing you know what's
going on I want to have this as feedback
this message will print out at a certain
time during my script so that's good
looks good
I hit escape : WQ and
it now let's see the moment of truth
we've created this script if I just type
good morning let's see what what we
expect it's this command not found let's
talk a little bit about all these
letters at the beginning so back in the
terminal here if I do LS - al we see at
the beginning of these files all these D
rwx are you know slash those are
impacting our ability to run that script
out of the command so chmod and file
folder permissions so this first blank
indicates the file type whether it's a
directory with a D or just a slash it's
a regular file from then we have these
three other groups one for the owner
members of the group and all other users
so that means any given file might have
different permissions for other people
on the computer you know as an owner I
might be able to do something but then
if somebody else logged into the machine
they would only be able to you know read
that file they couldn't execute whatever
that script was so where you want to do
who take a look at our newly created
scripts which is called good morning
nowhere is it executable we have our
read access W write access for the owner
so I'm allowed to make edits no one else
can make edits even but we want to have
X I'm not so concerned of if other users
have any access to this file I just want
to have access right now so what I'm
gonna do is type chmod plus X and then
the filename so if I do LS - al now I
see good morning has this X next to it
now it's red because it's an executable
script instead of just good morning
we're gonna do dots you know periods
slash good morning and it cleared the
terminal and did good morning world so
earlier it wasn't working because I was
just typing good morning and remember
when we're navigating throughout the
terminal it is relative and it matters
where we are so it didn't know exactly
where to look for a good morning here
but when we do dot slash me
go back director even look this / then
good morning their current directory and
/ then we're in good shape then it knows
exactly where to look so obviously this
is a very simple script example but
that's how easy it is anything that you
run in income in any command can be put
inside of a shell script whether it's
basic shell you know language things or
API calls or other programs so a lot to
know here there's a lot to to be done
and thank you hopefully you feel better
about using bash hopefully you feel like
you can not be so afraid of using your
terminal